I want to pull on this guy this guy who
puts big box around it it is the
relationship between a B and E
eccentricity okay and we're gonna unlock
why eccentricity is called eccentricity
yeah do you remember we've only seen a
very small number of values to college
right we started off with e who's 1
right that was actually where the game
began before we even knew it was called
eccentricity
if e equals 1 if the ratio between the
business of the focus and the distance
to the directory if that ratio is 1 then
the shape we get across is our parabola
right and then we just walked around
with a few other values right so Regina
ha where we got this awkward 0.66 1
whatever value and we ended up with
ellipses ok so now I want to try and
understand well
can I do better than just like trying to
pluck your random values and seeing what
happens and I can write those values
have you mentioned before they were all
less than 1 but by definition because
what you are comparing is a link and a
link they're all positive does that make
sense so I kind of know at least in this
kind of community unless than one and
every that you find will be less than 1
but I'm also above 0 right so I've got
I've got this like little sweet spot in
here that's that's behaving in unusual
ways now I have to say between because
it might say eccentricity equals 0 kind
of Matt breaks right because what is
eccentricities had I introduced it it's
a ratio it's a right here
it could have a ratio between two things
than 0 I don't care how big or small any
of them are a ratio of 0 doesn't make
sense ok
if only we had a kind of mathematics
that could deal with it like trying to
get to an actual number when you can't
put the action
not only I had a tool that was good at
doing that oh wait I do
they're called minutes right limits are
exactly what we introduced when it's
like I can't do rise over one where
there's the rug
and you can't have a ratio between two
things where there's no ratio okay but I
can examine what happens as it gets
closer and closer and closer and doing
that that first time gave us calculus
right so let's see what insecurities
that's right what happens to this what
is happening to B squared as I take the
limit as B approaches zero okay have a
look at this
I'm the limit as Z approaches here all
of this is the limit as a approaches you
are obvious they're the same thing
right so this is the limit as a
approaches 0 Oh a squared 1 minus a
square and a lovely beautiful thing
about this is that just like without
algebraic manipulation of first
principles I can put equal zero straight
into that I can just substitute it in
what we get I get a square times 1 which
is a square wait what does that mean
does that mean what's just happened
right the algebra main sentence galge
makes sense like zero there one - your
is one so that it has to be that what is
it me
well if B squared becomes a square then
this this is not your equation anymore
you get this right and now it makes
sense I can just multiply the whole
thing through by a square and I don't
get now for the second what's a what's a
M is on my lives it's the length of this
stop semi-major axis you have that so
that point right there is a do you do
that all a con zero
so where is that and the answer is it's
here it's a circle with the same width
across here as the major axis of my
ellipse okay now this circle is really
important it's so important to get a
name it's called the auxilary circle the
circle City on the outside of this
ellipse now what if we just establish
when eccentricity if it could equal zero
you get a circle circle circles
whispering galleries ellipses parabolic
reflectors they're all on the same
family and now I can tell me why
eccentricity is called eccentricity um
when you say centric right like
geocentric or heliocentric what a
century it means you know it means the
center right like a center middle
okay now unfortunately it's a it's a
it's a problem of English spelling and
an arm we have done this way this you
know the way I'm saying it eccentricity
a better way to spell it would be X
centricity that's actually the way to
say and that's the root of the word
we're comfortable when you put X on top
of in front of something what does that
mean like exterior yeah I mean it's
outside it means old way from like
external exterior right so if you
remember I said to you are an ellipse
it's got two foci it's as if the center
of the circle got broken in half and
kind of migrated away from the center
now the further they migrate the more of
a stretched out of X you get because
those centers get really really far
apart you get a highly eccentric ellipse
right and you remember I was talking
about the path of the Sun for the earth
anyone who's actually study like
astronomy they talk about the
eccentricity of the orbit of a comet or
a planet or a mood or whatever what
they're talking about is how close is it
or how far is it from being in perfectly
circular orbit so a comet for influence
comments we only see them every few
decades right that's because we haven't
all been kind of like this but a comet
hasn't ordered like this right it's
there's all this time all the way over
here and there's 70 years later how
these comet turns up again right because
I have a highly eccentric orbit this is
the language again
think about this right and interesting
increases what happens as our audiences
figure what happens as he approaches one
that was done once again well you get
limit as he approaches one of a squared
one take away N squared so that thing is
approaching one it's a Persian one take
away one this thing is going to zero
right
so B squared like this actually doesn't
make sense because it's on AG
denominator right but I know the
smallest value gets like being
represents these two values right so he
is getting smaller as well it's getting
smaller and smaller and smaller and more
eccentric okay I'm not going to tell you
the answer just yet but little teaser
right if you think about this because
we've looked at was what the zero well
that means we looked at between zero and
one
I know that means it's these are
businesses and I we already started with
one the obvious question is what happens
when you pass what watch this right when
he is greater than one
what do we know about V squared look at
them right remember peacefully squared
times 1 minus 2 squared if i sweared is
bigger than 1 what happens to this guy
he's negative flips on this side now
remembering that b is a length and we're
swearing it and apparently we're getting
something negative okay this tells us
that whatever it is it's something quite
different entirely
and we will meet it next week okay we
don't need to next week but there's
nothing stopping you remember I said hey
let's just experiment this let's just
let's just see what happens I have the
balls right you cannot use any two just
me you like bigger than one you pop it
into the moccasin definition and see
what jumps out we will meet as a class
on window